we play the bagpipes every morning
wherever her majesty the queen may be
and that would be at nine o'clock in the
morning
[Applause]
[Music]
the queen was fond of scotland and it
sound
wherever she was her date typically
began with the bagpipes a 15-minute
selection by her majesty's piper on the
stroke of 9am
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you would look up and you'd always see
her majesty the queen looking out just
to make sure that you are you're playing
well
because her majesty has a good year for
the rag pipes
scott methvin was the queen's piper for
four years he puts her love of the
instrument down to social occasions in
scotland as a youngster it would be all
these scottish balls that she would
attend and some of the tunes that i
would play in the morning reminded her
of
probably the happiest times when she
when her majesty was younger and was
able to get dancing with with her sister
and you know just happy times
[Music]
the royal family spend most of their
time in public duty and the british
people respect their few private hours
and leave them to enjoy their relaxation
like any other family of time spent in
scotland time on holiday was invariably
spent at balmoral their millions of
friends cannot all be there so we are
invited to meet them through the medium
of the camera
she was a queen with scottish roots a
descendant of robert the second king of
scots
her mother's ancestral home is in
scotland glam's castle in the county of
angus where elizabeth the queen mother
is remembered in photographs with the
child who would be queen
louise tate was the royal family's press
secretary in scotland for 15 years
she says the queen had an affinity with
a country and its people
there is a deep
understanding connection
and empathy
she gets
and gets how
scottish people tick
in terms of
what they get excited about what perhaps
doesn't excite them so much um
and she just really gets that
straightforwardness about scott scotland
she understands that you know scotland
does punch him of its weight in terms of
um
outlook one of the biggest exports is
people and people are always outward
looking and i think there's something
she admires about the scottish character
royal g-side had its royal duties not
least the famous bremar gathering
[Applause]
it's the annual highland games event the
visual spectacle that brings the crowds
and brought a smile to the royal ball
[Music]
away from the public eye this part of
the world offered summer seclusion in
places like this
honker house is the log cabin through
the woods
here the queen would go for a picnic or
barbecue with family and friends
she has spoken to me about how
difficult she found it to leave here
very often when the when the queen was
taking her leave she'd be looking out on
the start of
autumn colors and so on and she'd talk
about the seasons and how things are
things are
always going on there's these cycles and
she she would say and i suppose i'm
going to miss the best of the autumn
colors here
i must stay longer next time
a hundred miles south of balmoral is the
queen's official residence in scotland
the palace of holyrood house
in this corner of edinburgh's old town
it sits across the road from the seat of
political power the scottish parliament
at the start of each new session the
queen would make the journey next door
and meet the neighbors
[Applause]
it's a short trip but it was long on
sentiment when she addressed the chamber
for what would be the last time in 2021
i have spoken before
of my deep and abiding affection for
this wonderful country
and of the many happy memories prince
philip and i always held of our time
here
it is often said that it is the people
that make a place
and there are few places where this is
truer than in scotland
before scotland's 2014 independent
referendum the queen was heard to say
she hoped that voters would think very
carefully about the future
[Music]
whether or not that was a political
intervention the queen didn't
necessarily need big statements to have
a big influence
queen elizabeth ii has been an important
glue a bond of the union because she
herself has been very conscious of the
need to be aware of the different
nations which make up
the the british union that's especially
the case for scotland because of our
scottish ancestry going right back to
the medieval period and her special
concern
and i would say special love
for scotland
[Music]
back on royal decide paul anderson
played this tune for us
he played it for the queen in crafty
kirk
it's a lament for king george v her
grandfather
he's remembered here and so are other
monarchs passed
during the coronavirus pandemic the
queen was unable to attend crafty kirk
so she asked paul to play at a private
religious observance at balmoral castle
i think it was basically how much she
was missing that cider life there coming
up to kirk on a sunday i'd say it was
actually there was mere concern about
how you were coping actually was my
um
my feeling about it which i think is
probably gets lost as well that folk did
i see that personal thing she does care
about the folk that she knows for the
community and
um i think she felt for the focus
community and what they were going
through at the time
what scotland meant to the queen was it
was just truly part
part of your soul you know it was it was
everything to her absolute 100
[Music]
i will
miss the queen
dreadfully
people around here really respected the
queen
thought very very highly of her
[Music]
only now will people realise how just
how much she meant to their life and
when they reflect on the life that she
has led and the life of service and
dedication
and trying all the time to do what's
right for people
hey
[Music]
you